hi there i'm sam from simply learn and
i'm very glad to walk you through this
lesson about route 53 so in this section
we are going to talk about
basics of aws and then we're going to
immediately dive into
why
why we need amazon route 53 and then
we're going to expand and talk about the
details of amazon route 53 the benefits
it provides over its competitors and the
different types of routing policy it has
and some of amazon ralph 53's key
features and we're going to talk about
how to access route 53 i mean the
different ways the different methods you
can access route 53 and finally we're
going to end with an a wonderful demo in
drop 53 so let's talk about what is aws
amazon web services or aws in short is a
cloud provider that offers a variety of
services such as a variety of id
services or infrastructure services such
as a compute power database content
delivery and other resources that helps
us to scale and grow our business and
aws is hard aws is picking up aws is
being adapted by a lot of customers
that's because aws is easy to use even
for a beginner and talking about safety
the the aws infrastructure is designed
to keep the data safe irrespective of
the size of the data with small data be
it
very minimal data be it all the data
that you have in terabytes and in
petabytes amazon can keep it safe in
their environment and the wonderful
thing and the most important reason why
a lot of customers move into the cloud
is that the pay-as-you-go pricing there
is no long-term commitment and it's very
cost effective what this means is that
you're not paying for resource that
you're not using in on premises you do
pay for resources you're not using a lot
meaning you go and buy a server you do
the estimate for the next five years and
only after like three or four years
you'll be hitting the peak capacity but
still you would be buying that capacity
before four years right and then you
will gradually be you know utilizing it
from you know 40 percent date 60 days 70
80 and then 100. so what you have done
is that even though you're not using the
full capacity you still have bought it
and are and are paying for it from day
one but in the cloud it's not like that
you only pay for the resources that you
use anytime you want more you scale up
the resource and you you pay for the
scaled up resource and anytime you want
less you scale down the resource and you
pay less for that scaled down resource
let's talk about why amazon
route 53 let's take this scenario where
rachel is trying to open her web browser
and
the url that she hit isn't working a lot
of reasons behind why the url isn't
working it could be the server
utilization that went high it could be
it could be the memory usage that went
high a lot of reasons and she started to
think is there an efficient way to scale
resources according to the user
requirements or is there an efficient
way to kind of mask all those failures
and kind of divert the traffic to the
appropriate active you know active
resource or active service that's
running our application you always want
to hide the failures right in it kind of
mask the failure and direct the customer
to another healthy service that's
running right none of your customers
would want to see a server not available
or you know none of the customers your
customers would want to see your service
not working not impressive to them and
this is tom tom is an i.t guy and he
comes up with an idea and he's answering
rachel yes we can scale resources
efficiently using amazon rod 53 in a
sense he's saying that yes we can mask
the failure and we can keep the services
up and running meaning we can provide
more high availability to our customers
with the use of route 53 and then he
goes on and explains amazon drop 53 is a
dns service that gives developers an
efficient way to connect users to
internet applications without any
downtime now downtime is the key amazon
route 53 helps us to avoid any downtime
that customers will experience you still
will have downtime in your server and
your application but
your customers will not be made aware of
it and then rachel is kind of interested
and she's like yeah that sounds
interesting i want to learn more about
it and tom goes on and explains the
important concepts of amazon rock 53
that's everything that i'm gonna explain
it to you as well all right so what is
amazon rot53 amazon drop 53 is a highly
scalable dns or domain name system web
service
this service this amazon drop 53 it
functions three main things or it has
three main functions so the first thing
is if a website needs a name route 53
registers the name for the website
domain let's say you want to buy
google.com you want to buy the domain
name let's say you want to buy that
domain name you buy that through route53
secondly a route 53 is the service that
actually connects your
server which is running your application
or which is holding which is serving
your web page so that's the service that
actually route 53 is the service that
connects the user to your server when
they hit google.com in the browser or
whatever domain name that you have
purchased so you bought a domain name
and the user types in
yourdomainname.com and then roth53 is a
service that helps the user to connect
their browser to the application that's
running in an ec2 instance or any other
server that you are using to serve that
content and not only that rot53 checks
health of the resource by sending
automated requests over the internet to
a resource so that's how it identifies
if there is any resource that has failed
when i say resource i'm referring to any
infrastructure failure any application
level failure so it kind of keeps
checking so it understands it first
before the customer notices it and then
it does the magic kind of shifts the
connection from a one server to the
other server we call it routing we will
talk about that as we progress so the
benefits of using route53 it's highly
scalable meaning suddenly let's say the
number of requests the number of people
trying to access your website through
that domain name that you have bought
let's say it has increased ralph 53 is
highly scalable right it can handle even
millions and millions of requests
because it's highly scalable and it's
managed by amazon uh the same thing it's
reliable it's a highly scalable it can
handle large queries without the users
without you interacting without the user
who bought it interact with it you don't
have to scale up you know when you're
expecting more requests it automatically
uh scales and it is very reliable in a
sense that
it's very consistent
it has the ability to route the users to
the appropriate application through the
logic that it has it's very easy to use
when we do the lab you're gonna see that
it's very easy easy to use you buy the
domain name and then you simply map it
to the application you simply map it to
the server by putting in the ip or if
you you can simply map it to another
load balancer by putting in the load
balancer url you can simply map it to
another
s3 bucket by simply putting the s3
bucket name or the sd bucket url it's
pretty straightforward easy to set up
and it's very cost effective in a way
that we only pay for the service that we
have used so no wastage of money here so
the billing is set up in such a way that
you are paying only for the amount of
requests that
you have received right the amount of
traffic the amount of requests that you
have received and couple of other things
the the number of uh
hosted zones that you have created right
and a couple of other things
it's very cost effective in such a way
that you only pay for the service that
you are using and it's secure in a way
that access to route 53 is
integrated with identity and access
management iam so you only have
authorized users
gain access to route 53 the trainee who
just joined us today won't get access
and the contractor or the consultant the
third party consultant you have given
access or who is using your environment
you can block access to that particular
person because he's not the admin or
he's not a privileged user in your
account so only privileged users and
admin gain access to route 53 through
iam now let's talk about the routing
policies so when you create a record in
in route 53 recorder is nothing but an
entry so when you do that you choose a
routing policy right routing policy is
nothing but it determines how route 53
responds to your queries how the dns
queries are being responded right that's
that's a record or that's a routing
policy so the first one is a simple
routing policy so we use simple
routing policy for a single resource in
other words simple routing allows to
configure dns with no special raw 53
routing it's kind of one to one you use
an single resource that performs a given
function to your domain for example if
you want to simply map an url to a web
server that's pretty straightforward
simple routing so it routes traffic to a
single resource example web server to a
website and with simple routing multiple
records with the same name cannot be
created
but multiple values can be created in
the same record the second type of
routing policy is failover routing so we
would be using failover routing when we
want to configure active passive
failover if something failed right you
want to fail over to the next resource
which was previously the backup resource
now the active resource or which was
previously the backup server now it's an
active server so you would be failing
over to that particular resource or that
particular ip if you want to do that we
use failover routing so failover routing
routes traffic to a resource when the
resource is healthy or to a different
resource when the previous resource is
unhealthy in other words anytime a
resource goes unhealthy i mean it does
all that's needed to shift the traffic
from the primary resource to the
secondary resource in other words from
the unhealthy resource to the healthy
resource and this records can route
traffic to
anything from an
amazon
s3 bucket or you can also configure a
complex tree of records now when we
configure the records it will be more
clear to you so as of now just
understand that route 53 can route or
this routing policy the failover routing
policy can route traffic to amazon s3
bucket or to a website that has complex
tree of records geolocation routing
policy now geolocation routing just like
the name says it takes that routing
decision based on the geographic
location of the user in other words you
know when you want to route traffic
based on the location of the user that's
your primary criteria for you know
sending that request to the appropriate
server we will be using geo
location routing so it localizes the
content and presents a part or the
entire website in the language of the
user for example a user from us
you would want to direct them to an
english website and a user from german
if you want to send them to the german
website and a user from france you know
you want to send those requests or you
want to show content specific to a
customer who lives in france a french
website so this is if that's your
condition this is the routing policy we
would be using
and the geographic locations are
specified by either continent or by
country or by state in the united states
so only in the united states you can
actually split it to state level and for
the rest of the countries you can do it
on a country level on a high level you
can also do it on a continent level the
next type of routing policy would be
your proximity routing geoproximity
routing policy when we want to route
traffic based on the location of our
resource and optimally shift traffic
from resources in one location to
resource in another location we would be
using geoproximity routing so
geoproximity routing routes traffic to
the resources based on the geographic
location of the user and the resources
they want to access and it also has an
option to route
more traffic or less to a given resource
by specifying a value known as a bias
kind of weight but we also have weighted
routing that's different so we've chosen
different name buyers so you can send
more traffic to a particular resource by
uh having a bias on that particular
routing condition and a bias expands or
shrinks the size of the geographic
region from which traffic is routed to a
resource and then we have latency based
routing just like the name says we use
latency based routing if we have
resources in multiple aws regions and if
you want to route traffic to the region
that provides the best latency at any
given point of time so
let's say if one single website needs to
be installed and hosted on multiple aws
regions then latency routing policy is
what is being used it improves the
performance of the users by serving the
request from the aws region that
provides the lowest
latency so at any given point if
performance is your criteria and at any
given point of time irrespective of what
happens in amazon infrastructure
irrespective of what happens in the
internet if you want to route your users
to the best performing website best
performing region then we would be using
latency based dropping and for using
latency based routing we should create
latency records for the resources in
multiple aws regions and then the other
type of
a routing policy is a
multi-value routing policy where we can
make route 53 to respond to dns queries
with up to eight healthy records
selected at
random so you're not kind of loading one
particular server we can define eight
records and on a random basis route 53
will respond to queries from these eight
records so it's not one server that gets
all the requests but
eight servers
gets the request in a random fashion so
it's multi-value routing policy and what
we get by this is that we are
distributing the traffic to many servers
instead of just one server so
multi-value routing configures route 53
to return multiple values in response to
a single or multiple dns queries it also
checks the health of
order sources and returns the multiple
values only for the healthy resources
let's say out of the eight servers we
have define one server is not doing
healthy it will not respond to the query
with the details of the unhealthy server
right so now it's gonna treat it as only
seven servers in the list because one
server is unhealthy and it has the
ability to return multiple health
checkable ip addresses to improve
availability and
load balancing the other type of routing
policy is weighted routing policy and in
here we use
to route traffic or this is used to
route traffic to multiple resources in a
proportion that we specify so this is an
weighted routing and weighted routing
routes multiple resources to a single
domain name or a sub domain and control
the traffic that's routed to each
resources so this is very useful when
you're doing load balancing and testing
new versions of the software so when you
have a new version of the software you
really don't want to send 100 of the
traffic to it so you want to get
customers feedback about the new
software that you've launched new
version or new application that you've
launched so you would kind of send only
20 of the traffic to that application
get customer feedback and if all is good
then we would move the rest of the
traffic to that new application so any
software launches application launches
will be using weighted routing now let's
talk about the key benefits or key
features of route53 some of the key
features of rouse53 are a traffic flow
it routes end users to the endpoint that
should provide the best user experience
that's what we discussed in the routing
policies right it uses a routing policy
a latency based routing policy and jio
based routing policy and then failover
routing policy so it kind of improves
the user experience and the key feature
the other key feature of route 53 is we
can buy domain names using a roth 53
using route 53 console we can buy it
from here and use it in route 53.
previously it was not the case but now
we can buy it directly from amazon
through route 53 and we can assign it to
any resources that we want so anybody
browsing that url the connection will be
directed to the server in aws that runs
our website a health checks it monitors
health and performance of the
application so it comes with an health
check attached to it health check are
useful to make sure that the unhealthy
resources are retired right the
unhealthy resources are taken away or
your customers are not kind of hitting
the unhealthy resources and they see an
service down page or something like that
uh we can have weighted
round robin load balancing that's
helpful and spreading
traffic between several services or
servers we are round robin algorithm so
no one server is fully hit or no one
server kind of fully absorbs all the
traffic you know you can shift you can
split and shift the traffic to different
servers based on the weight that you
would be configuring and also weighted
routing also helps with
a soft launch
soft launch of your new application or
the new version of your website there
are different ways we can access amazon
route 53 so you can access amazon route
53 through aws console you can also
access amazon route 53 using aws sdks
and we can access it using we can
configure it using the apis and we can
also do it through the command line
interface that's linux type linux flavor
aws command line interface we can also
do that using windows command line
windows powershell flavored command line
interface as well now let's look at some
of the companies that are using ros 53
so some of the famous companies that use
route 53 are
medium medium is an online publishing
platform and
it's more like a social
journalism it's kind of having hybrid
collection of uh professionals people
and publications or exclusive blogs or
publishers on medium it's kind of an
blog website and that uses rot53 for the
dns service reddit is an uh social news
aggregation or web content rating and
discussion website that uses rod 53s so
these are some websites that that are
accessed throughout the world and they
are using roth 53 and it's highly
scalable suddenly there is a new news
right their website will be accessed a
lot and
they need to keep their service up and
running all the time more availability
otherwise
customers will end up in a broken page
and
the number of customers who will be
using the website will come down so it's
very critical these sites these
companies are very critical you know
they're being highly available their
page their site being highly available
and the internet is very critical and
crucial for them and they rely and use
route 53 to meet that particular demand
and airbnb is
another company uh instacart cosr is
another company stripe is another
company that uses route53 to as their
dns
provider for the dns
service they use route 53 so their
customers get best performance they use
raw 53 so their website is highly
available they use route 53 to kind of
shift to the traffic between the
resources so their resources are
properly used with all the weighted
routing the resources are properly used
now let's quickly look at a demo i'm in
my aws console and i'm in route53 so let
me click on rot53 so in this lab we're
actually going to simulate buying a
domain name and then we're going to
create an s3 static website and we're
going to map that website to this
dns name right so the procedure is the
same for mapping load balancer the
procedure is the same for mapping
cloudfront the procedure is the same for
mapping ec2 instances as well we're
picking s3 for simplicity right but our
focus is actually on route 53. so let's
go in here and i will see if we can we
will buy a domain name here so let's
first check the availability of a domain
name called simply learn hyphen demo
hyphen route 53 let's check its
availability it is available for 12
dollars so let me add it to cart and
then come back here and then once you
continue it'll ask for personal
information once you give the personal
information you finally check out and
then it gets added to your shopping list
once you pay for it amazon takes like 24
to 40 hours to make that a dns name
available so the next stage would be
contact details and then the third stage
would be verify and purchase so once we
have bought the domain name it will
become available in our dns portal and i
do have a domain name which i bought
some time back and it's now available
for me to use so i can go to hosted zone
and simply start creating i can go to
hosted zone and then here it's going to
list all the domain names for me right
click on the domain name and then click
on the record set and here i can
actually map elastic load balancer s3
website vpc endpoint api gateway and
cloudfront elastic bean stock domain
names right all that gets mapped through
this portal quite simple like four or
five step
button clicks and then it'll be done so
i have an
domain name bot and then i'm gonna go to
s3 and i'll show you what i've done in
s3 so i've created a bucket name called
as
a dns name let me clear the content in
them so i've created a bucket and then
permissions i've turned off public
access blocking and then i've created an
a bucket policy so this bucket is now
publicly accessible and then i went on
the properties and created the static
website hosting right and i've pointed
that this is the file that's my index
file that i'm going to put or name of
the file that's going to be my index
file that i'm going to put in this s3
bucket so put the index file.html saved
it
and
we're going to create a file now we're
going to create an index file so this is
a sample code it says amazon.53 getting
started routing internet traffic to s3
bucket for your website and then a
couple of other information so save it
as an
index.html file in my desktop so let me
upload that from my desktop into this
bucket so that's index.html and it's in
capital i so let me go to properties and
go to static website hosting and make
sure that i spell it properly right it's
case sensitive and then save it so now
this means that my website should be
running through this url and it does
it's running to the static website url
we're halfway through so now let me go
back to route53 go back to route53 go
back to hosted zones go into the domain
name and then create a record set and
it's going to be an alias record and i i
see my s3 static website endpoint there
right so click on it and create it has
now created an
record that's pointing my domain name to
the s3 endpoint that i have created and
my static website is running from it so
let me test it right so let me go to the
browser put the domain name in there and
sure enough the domain name when my
browser queried for the domain name a
ros 53 returned a response saying this
domain name is actually mapped to the s3
bucket static website hosting enable s3
bucket and this is the url for that
static website hosting and then my
browser was able to connect to that s3
bucket and download the details and show
it in my browser right so it's that
simple and pretty straight forward thank
you for watching this video i believe
you enjoyed the content we will meet
again through another video like this
thank you again and bye for now
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here